[Music]
i guess it is pretty green to me it's
not
it wasn't just always all green now i'm
quite green
my name is elizabeth
sweetheart and
i am the green lady
everything is green
i brought green counter and then i got
green knobs and then all the accessories
we even painted the front door green
if i find something that i really like
in terms of clothing and what i wear
i make it green
[Music]
these are my overalls
i grew up with my family in nova scotia
and they didn't know what to do with me
i wanted to be an artist
i started wearing green when my dad
invited me to visit florida it was
really exciting for me to go because we
hadn't really connected and he didn't
really care for an artist
the water is aqua green deep rich greens
i painted all the palm trees and from
that point on i started adding little
bits of green because it was like a
lucky day that dad asked me to go visit
it's been around 17 to 20 years
i continue to wear green because the way
i dress makes other people smile and say
oh the green lady
[Music]
can i have a selfie with you
i think people really really like the
belief that you like something enough to
really
carry it through
when you're young you tend to think you
look good in black as you get older you
realize color is so much fun i will
continue to be green because it's so
positive i think when it's not then i'll
change
to my next favorite thing
you